well i might welcome another episode i
knew it i knew it
a big moment nature mood massive mood
[ __ ] massive i mean it's massive
that's what she said isn't it
i don't know i'm not participating i
didn't
except nikki i'm a i'm the babysitter
he's the sober one i'm sober
i took a shot and a half gina took a
shot gina took a shot
also didn't eat lunch eating today so
yeah she had not
please it's like half a shot are you
guys prefacing them for like i'm letting
you know that this might be a hot mess
the insanity
yes it was my mental illness and there's
a mental illness in it it's a drinking
problem in it
it's a drinking problem it's a drinking
problem yeah um
so listen i'm gonna tell you guys right
now um
i had to write down all the questions
and after i took the shot the
handwriting has gotten
significantly worse questions yeah so so
that's where we are i'm just gonna warn
you guys it's because i drank and i
hadn't
started writing in cursive just like
your speech it's in vietnamese the
second half you're speaking in cursive
you can't even handle english anymore um
it's squatting
for you to ask us questions in enemies i
feel like we're gonna be like on the
same level of drunk that i'm gonna
understand the vietnamese yeah that's
gonna be great
it's gonna be great hi welcome to
another episode
of big mood [ __ ] um and today's episode
that's our old name with our new name
it's okay
but i'm not good at it um today's
episode we looked up boy [ __ ]
[ __ ] today's episode oh i'm australian
we're asking questions that men are
afraid to ask women and we
pulled this from reddit and it was my
job to
uh pick the best questions i'm
gonna be asking these [ __ ] hoes the
questions and we're gonna answer it
so we can answer the scared men that
want to ask these questions
but are scared and we got like some long
ones some short ones
um so that's how typically how they go
it's true and if you guys have any
questions that you're afraid to ask
women
please leave it in the comments below
but without further ado
let's [ __ ] jump right into it if i
can do it mate
[ __ ] do it are we australian or are
we i don't know i don't know
we're just gonna teeter we're gonna yeah
we're just gonna sit here
love island so it's all uk based for me
i just discovered chav
rap because of chav tiktok and uh man
that's that's a lot of foundation you
guys wear i don't know what that is i
don't know what that
it's it's yeah it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
okay
um does sex without a condom really make
a difference yes
[ __ ] yeah it drives me the [ __ ] out
condoms
i had to do mind tricks to like it
because uh when i got off birth control
it was the first time
in a relationship that like i had to use
condoms
um and the only other time i used
condoms was when like it was doing
casual sex
you know like to protect yourself yes so
but then i
i've talked about this before but you
know doing it with steve i had to
pretend like oh i'm doing a hookup you
know like he's a stranger that's why we
got to wear a condom
he might be dirty we don't know who this
guy's been
and so he's so high yeah
i can't wait i can't wait to find out in
two weeks
i'm just not gonna let this guy hit it
right you know what i'm saying
um so really yeah we can expand on that
no it really feels like it's like a like
a dildo almost like a warmth
it like turns to plastic yeah it's just
way uncomfortable
friction is gone yes the skin to skin
well it's well the inside of our vagina
is not really skin
it's like tissue i guess but like the
warmth of our tissue
grasping squamous heart that hard
[ __ ]
yes yes keep going
jess she's like whoa
but yeah no we can feel the difference
yeah i mean i it's too smooth
yeah yeah yeah yeah really yeah i can't
tell the difference
what no it's not like you don't have the
[ __ ] mind connection that's right i
don't need to work on that it doesn't
it doesn't change strength in your [ __ ]
line connection
right now um it doesn't change the
pleasure factor for me
it changes the uh it makes me dry yeah
yeah
for sure the friction gets worse yeah
and then so like when it gets too dry
the condoms you dry like okay let's
change it out and you have to keep on
doing that yeah
or use lube you can use lube okay
actually one thing i discovered recently
because i had a yeast infection sorry
guys
all of you who are in love with me i did
have yeast infection a few weeks ago
i found out that lube i found out that
lube can give you a yeast infection so
like ky jelly or astroglide if it has
glycerin in it it can
it can cause yeast infections
my vagina is perfectly fine okay it's
actually moisturizing too i love it the
next day
honestly i used to get dry until i did
the mental trick of um
pretending it was a hookup and it really
made a difference but even in a hookup
cause i
that's all i have now are hookups and
i'm like oh the [ __ ] condom
sucks oh the threat of stds
you like danger no i don't want anyone
to actually have an std but
it's like a rule i have that you don't
get to hit it without a condom no matter
from birth control
if if we're not in a relationship and so
you know you could even say you got
tested 10 times for stds you're still
not hitting it without a condom
because i also don't want to get
pregnant from you
like and we're not in a relationship um
so yeah uh but yeah it could be a bad
boy
i don't know i don't know his life she's
like yeah
tell me about your genital warts tell me
about the recent blood tests you had to
do
did they get the did you get the phone
call how'd those scabies feel oh cop
burning
scabies that's not an std it is
one that was that we learned about in
health class it's not an std
but you can get it through sexual
encounters scabies
yeah i've never heard that so let's move
on
we had a fake band called rotting
scabies too
okay the wrong hole
yeah for me if it's like wait reminder
nikki's sober by the way yeah
i am picking up on i've had the most
alcohol and i think i'm holding it
together
pretty well i'm actively dying right now
i really do feed off whatever energy's
around me
you're like pulling my jacket like you
could not get drunk because i'm taking
it
you're like a vampire like succubus oh
you little succubus
a if you were a vampire and you're like
hey can i
i'm just like yeah go ahead buddy just
don't kill me i know just don't kill me
you're so cute
um yeah for me it's like if if we had
lube like the wetness problem wasn't a
thing
yeah i would be perfectly fine that's
crazy to me you know i actually prefer
coconut oil uh than my own natural
juices
i mean they're great i need to do
something because i thought it wasn't
good
i really like the sensation of the
coconut oil you like the oily slippery
yeah but it's not super slippery where
you no longer like really yeah because
there's like a problem
there's a point where it's too bad yeah
that happens with my juices i think
because it's oil
yeah i think because it's oil it's like
there's still more friction yeah like a
watery thing
you guys try the super thin condoms
those aren't bad they don't do
it's all the same at all so really have
you tried the ribbed ones
yes i hate those oh i hate those even
more do
anything okay if a guy pulls out a
ribbon i'm like oh
no why i don't know it's like it's it's
like
it hurts almost we can only do magnums
so i can't really
yeah they don't have a ribbon that's not
a maximum then i'm just not gonna have
sex
steve doesn't even use a magnum he uses
the rubber balloons at party city
yeah i do feel you're paying gentlemen
that you have to use condoms and you
hate it i know
because so do i guess we still have to
we're trying to be responsible
okay okay so the next question is
um do you ever masturbate while thinking
of your male
friends yeah no like the jk crew no
no like actual friend youtube no yeah no
i think of a girl getting pounded by
eight men
wow that's pretty dope i don't think of
anything
i just get off by the sensation really
but it feels like i never think of
anything i watch
porn yeah i have to think of something
i'll gather the bits
that i like about porn and like put them
into one i don't have an imagination so
i have to watch it
no and then if i ever do watch porn
because i feel weird that i don't
because i'm like well it's normal to
watch porn i guess i should watch
something you don't have to
you don't have to if you're if you get
off by the sensation that's done oh yeah
but then sometimes like i'll feel like
like a slight tingling of like oh i'm a
little bit horny but like let me
try checking out some porn and i'll get
really horny and then i'll really get
into it
so like that's kind of like an appetizer
or whatever
but i actually like as soon as i start
touching myself like i turn it off and i
i don't even look at it yeah and i just
i like get in with myself i have to skip
to the [ __ ] shot
oh if i need to expedite the process
then i watch porn but like if anything
else like if i'm all right i can take my
time but if it's like one of those like
i need to get out of the way so i can go
to sleep then porn makes me orgasm
really fast so you're watching it as
you're you're going on i have like a few
go-to's in my head and if one's not
working then i switch to the next go-to
yeah dang you have like a spank bang
oh yeah dangerous recently not a porn of
my own like stories
or your own experience well not
experiences like my own like created
imaginary scenarios your brains are so
creative
dude recently uh because i had never
tried this before
but i was actually thinking of a
celebrity and that actually got me all
connected wow
it wasn't just it was the one we all
agree on
really
ever because i'm like i need personality
like
random ones honestly he's not that
objectively hot
yeah that's why i was shy i don't know i
like it
takes all of our boxes it does
it was never a thing for me because like
i see even even stevens i know yeah
and holes it's two different people two
different people
but the recent tattoo photos yeah oh
he's so hot
i was thinking of in my brain yeah see
me it was because i'm like well it has
to be personality or something before
their personality no but like when he
started doing the trolling stuff where
he was doing that i'm not famous or
whatever and like
he did that one video where um that
those people did a takedown of him and
he was in the audience clapping
oh yeah like when he does [ __ ] like that
i'm like all right
dude it's all the recent movies i've
seen yeah the recent stuff that made me
like
oh [ __ ] really like american honey
yeah uh there's no honey honey boy no no
american honey american honey
you're sponsored by honey hey shout out
to honey and we actually are two movies
with honey
there is no but recently though we went
to a q and a
honeyboy he was literally like
as close as like that mirror like he was
so close and like just
if you ever present do that again
without me i will kill you wait is it
tall
it was just like neck down for me
because i didn't really care much about
the face but you guys know i am with
tattoos so when that photo came out i'm
like
yeah that's nice i like that no and then
just like seeing him like just the way
he was like just sitting there and like
and he had like a baseball
hat so i couldn't really see his eyes so
it was just so like sexy you know what
else he's really sexy the hot wings or
the hot ones
youtube channel when he was on he was
like eating just hot wings and i was
like you know what
i want to [ __ ] that guy yeah i don't
want to be that hot wing in his mouth
yeah what was the question
i forgot
the question was do you ever masturbate
thinking of your mouth
i think about nasty people like they're
not like real
people but they're just yeah like just
like people getting their rocks off
oh like dirty like yeah like i like when
it gets taboo like like guys
masturbating
or something yeah dude my friends like i
like they are just so far away
like the complete opposite end of ever
me just ever being turned on to the
point where like if i if we're all
sharing an airbnb
and just know my friends are around i
cannot get
turned on i can't like i i just yeah
yeah that's true i think guys want to
know because they probably masturbate to
their platonic friends from time to time
they're like
do they ever do it to me too and i think
for us it's kind of like nah unless we
have a crush on you
like and it's like secretly we want more
than just to be friends i don't
i don't think i've ever masturbated to a
random guy
like if i ever masturbated to you that
means you're not my friend i'm actively
pursuing you maybe
you know so i think i have once actually
oh
but then yeah and then i realized that i
was just like unhappy
um with my ex right and i was just like
projecting on to other guys so i started
masturbating to i've never masturbated
to anyone i know in real life
ever like not people i had a crush on
not anything like it's always leave
oh no because you're all about like oh
the the stranger
oh i'm at a club and this guy starts
dancing with me and then he takes his
dick out and he just puts it in it's
like oh [ __ ] you shouldn't
you're not allowed to do that it's like
taboo i don't even know what his face
looks like it's just the feeling of like
some guys taking advantage when they're
not supposed to [ __ ] that i would never
let anyone do in real life
scenario versus actual person
um okay so next question is does height
really matter no yes yes it does
it does yes i've made it i've dated at
least three
short-ish guys too yeah so what's the
shortest
five-six okay same yeah so and then i
had like a five seven
five eight-ish so i've dated like three
guys that were i guess what you would
consider to be short yeah i still dated
them i was in long-term relationships
with them but
it is still something i guess it's like
if you're a tit guy and you just happen
to fall in love with a girl with no tits
i.e me you know like you're you're okay
with it you still love that person but
you would prefer them to have
kids if you're a tick guy you prefer
them to have tits and but so i've dated
them
but for me it still matters it makes a
difference on my attraction level it
makes a difference
that's true because like i had an ex who
if i wore heels we were
practically the same height or i think
we're higher a little taller
yeah yeah depending on the heel size and
that to me just made me feel so
like unattracted to him for that reason
unfortunately i know
there's so many like really yeah it's
it's acts it's like
absolutely superficial we know that we
know that's absolutely shitty to say
yeah i've never been like the height and
has never mattered to me
um most physical features don't because
if you have a good enough personality or
like i connect you you're automatically
the
most attractive person to me except for
i will say the one physical thing that's
ever turned me off
was too skinny like and that's only came
into play when we were having sex
because if i feel your pelvic bone like
digging into me and like you're way
skinnier than me it just makes me feel
weird
yeah like if you're 20 pounds lighter
than me
i can't if you're like 6-1 and you're
also 150 pounds and i'm 5'4 and i'm 150
pounds
it's kind of weird you're like a noodle
i can't do it
i needed a tall skinny guy didn't matter
though because his dick was huge so i'm
not i'm not feeling your pelvic bone i'm
feeling a dick
oh the one that we all saw oh that one
i first started dating he was way too
skinny and i told him i was like
really scared you need to gain weight
yeah when casey goes on his diets like
there was this one time he was trying to
be like only vegan and he had like zero
red meat or anything he started getting
really scrawny i'm like honey
you better like just pack on i've never
seen that was that before i came around
i've never seen no yeah it's been
it's been recent i mean i mean also you
don't see him
oh i don't see him that much but and
then like also with the clothes it kind
of hides it a bit but
like he'll like if we're having sex and
he's just like a little too like it's
mainly like around the arms like
sometimes you'll get a little too
scrawny where i'm like
yeah yeah it's like i'm so attracted to
them i'm still
like in love you know i was still in
love with steve but
i was just like i would just be like and
i didn't want to tell him to change at
all like and
i but he had just lost like 50 pounds
because he
like got out of a relationship and like
wasn't eating very much and was like the
anxiety
weight loss yeah and i was like hey
maybe
you know let's eat a little bit you know
you can't eat some steak and potatoes
those things are changeable you know
they're not yeah they're not
static but like height unfortunately i
like a thick boy
i can't do it and i'd say i say this all
the time like it's because i'm not
strong enough
to do it you know and i know it's such a
cop-out it really is it's
just extremely superficial
and you know you need to deal with that
no i will not
i will stick to my guns i mean that's
one thing i realized i am
superficial when it comes to that and i
feel bad about that i feel guilty i know
that short guys deserve love
but there's also a ton of shorter girls
like five two girls that will love you
just
i will not be ashamed of my preferences
yo lately
so i used to be like oh anyone over a
certain age i'm not really attracted to
but lately i've i've thought older guys
are kind of hot you're getting
yeah hella going hard on 40 year olds
especially like they have a better
personality
for the most part like a lot of them
have like learned some [ __ ] yeah
and a little bit of gray is getting hot
yeah not a lot not like a silver fox but
like
brown with the grays coming in i'm like
okay you've got some wisdom in mine
yeah i'm not there yet i see some grays
popping out and i'm like let's pluck
those out
we'll have it superficial uh maybe you
had someone come to your door
that wasn't a suitor but did have a lot
of food for you
i do like because of you ordering it i
like when people show up to my door
with food um and now you can do that
with doordash
because you don't want to go outside
ever like me
between never-ending laundry cycles and
incoming email you've got plenty to do
on your to-do list
give yourself one less thing to worry
about and let doordash take care of your
next meal
doordash is an app that brings all the
food that you want
to your door all of it so if you too
skinny you order all that yeah
don't be too skinny guys when steve and
casey were too skinny we had doordash
we can order anything tons of french
fries pack it in boys
fried chicken we can order anything from
chipotle
wendy's and cheesecake factory and it's
delivered to your door
with no contact because you know maybe
they don't want to be seen
maybe i don't want to be seen maybe we
just don't want to get coronavirus yeah
an adult
a layer of protection you know
oh gross chicken i love the contact list
delivery option now and i'm just like
please keep it forever
yeah yeah yeah i think it was true i
like nuts it's much easier for everyone
to
have to deal with people i like that
because when i'm at home
the way i look never makes sense you
know what i mean and i don't want to
open the door
how do i get this door dash so right now
our listeners can get five dollars off
and zero delivery fees on their first
order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
big mood that's five dollars off your
first order and
zero zero delivery fees if you uh
download the doordash app now in the app
store and answer code big mood
don't forget that's big mood for five
dollars off your first order
with doordash nice yeah that makes me
smile
what a professional that makes you smile
i will never get to the nikkilimo level
of professionalism
so would you like to eat your food with
straight or crooked teeth
with straight teeth because i don't want
my choppers hitting each other oh yeah
and you accidentally bite your cheek
that happens to me
oh yeah you know what guys my friends at
candid can help candid clear aligners
are comfortable removable and totally
invisible
unlike your dorky wire braces uh you can
transform your smile
i know i'm sorry you can transform your
smile without anyone noticing
plus your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
with candida your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan so
you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
the average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
actually way faster than that and it
actually costs an average
of 50 less than other brands
so get ready to take the first step
towards getting your dream smile that
you can't wait to show
off get started today from the comfort
of your own home with candid
risk free starter kit and 75 off
go to candidco.com mood and use our code
mood to let them know that we sent you
that's candidco.com
mood with our code mood to start uh to
get your risk free starter kit and 75
off 75 one more time that's candidco.com
mood with our code mood with 75 bucks
off
dude that reminds me of this oh go ahead
i'm sorry
i just want to throw this in there
because it has like you went in and then
pulled out
it has to do with the ad um so last time
we did an episode i talked about how i
was very
self-conscious about my [ __ ] because
i have a bracelet in the back of my
teeth
yeah and i was i was afraid of scraping
the wiener schnitzel
yeah um my dentist messaged me and said
hey i
uh i have a confession to make i was
like what what he goes
i watched your episode and i died
laughing
about the whole brace thing and i was
just like oh my god why did you watch
this you're so only supposed to know
about one orifice in my body
did he offer you some free wax or
something
so he was just like i laughed so hard
and he's like i didn't know if i should
bring it up because now whenever i work
on your teeth i'm going to giggle every
time i tell you
he's going to be picturing a dick and
balls on your chin every time your mouth
is flat
open in that chair and then he's like by
the way so i asked him was okay so on a
different note
do you have any wax that i can cover my
nice and smooth he goes
you know as a dentist i'm supposed to
help you live comfortably with your
teeth and yes that includes the wax so
yes you can come pick somebody up
he's like i will bless the men in your
life yeah thanks mike i love you
side note i gotta hit him up and get
some of those retainers when i'm done
with my treatment yeah because my
orthodontist doesn't do the zigzags
and i'm like this ain't acceptable yeah
go to mike he's amazing now that he
knows about my butthole
shout out to mike what's our next
question tina
this is a um one for nikki
do you notice when the balls are
slapping against your butt oh yeah i
love that
hell yeah those tease balls
guys are far too big stupid [ __ ]
questions yeah i mean can't you feel it
you don't think you're an audience it's
an audience clapping you on like it's
[ __ ]
i feel encouraged everyone hears it i
actually hate hearing the sound of it
really but recently
update on our sex life um
no no the house was empty and there was
just
i don't know we just kind of fell into
it and then i was just like you know
getting really loud i started screaming
and stuff and
you got loud for what yeah yeah i did i
got loud for once and then he got loud
and we were just like going wild
and we're like oh because i was in the
house
that's actually tiff not even casey
yeah and then also um i was asking him
like
hey so can we try a thing where you're
kind of like way more dominant because
like
i'd be really hot nice and then he was
and then we had the best sex every night
congrats communication that's awesome
i love looking up and seeing a guy going
like oh you know me too like especially
like if you're in a hotel room and
there's mirrors everywhere like you
could see them pounding you and you're
like oh my god i'm a porn
oh my god at our old place in the closet
area there was like
two sliding mirror door closet thingies
and we'd have sex there all the time
nice it was nice yeah
i like the aggression nice i like balls
on the ass so yeah
you can feel that it doesn't really do
anything but i think it's like you're
getting
spanked for oh and then yeah and then
he's starting
to and i used to hate that before but
then this time he was spanking and i was
like
it was like i think it was an authentic
moment and that's what worked
for you these balls are so big they
swing and hit my stomach
my gosh what is wrong with when he's
hitting a missionary silence hitting the
back
behind that's why people are like you
know i talked about him being a never
knew and like how he like
pulls it out of his box but it's like
you have to restrain those boys
it's like hitting your [ __ ] the whole
time you're like yeah you know those
testicles that they hang in the back of
trucks
it was muddled after steve's mom
i wonder what happened to like did he
get did he have an injury that like made
his balls smile
i think that's what makes him so
confident he's got ginormous balls
yeah i just don't know why they hang so
low well they're they
it's like they're big though it's not
even like they're like on a string and
they're like
i know old man balls like they start
getting lower and they start sagging
but like kids are just big because i
pictured do you remember the movie joe
dirt where the dog got his balls
stuck to the porch and then he's like
trying to get up and so there's just
like this long bit of skin with two
little balls that's what i picture
steve's balls to look like they're just
hanging up like that
i don't think
they're like the dice in the mirror of a
were steve i would mold my balls and
make christmas ornaments out of them and
send them to all my friends yes
please don't steve especially to tiff no
please don't
i'll burn them i'll use it as missile
until like oh we're standing under this
and your boyfriend's like so these are
your friends
balls your boyfriend your husband's like
this is not appropriate
in fact it's our christmas party he's
standing right over there yeah all the
guys are in the corner at the party
together like should we kick his ass i
think we should
i sort of feel like i'm gonna kick his
ass it's good luck if you make out under
his balls
or like it's a good thing when you leave
the house every day you just tap it
before
steve's balls find everlasting love
after bless
i'm down to try it running out of
options so
um okay so the next question is uh what
are some flirting techniques that you've
done that are not so obvious
um the arms learning you're so
funny that's obvious yeah you know
everything's obvious we're like oh
oh let me see what's on your phone and
then i'll just like push my boob against
their arm
probably asking for help with something
oh because
you know like making yourself needy
that's true that's a good one
i need help like doing this thing
people think of being mean like in
elementary school yeah the hell could
you potentially total [ __ ] to
some guy sometimes i just like to bust
balls like i'm well and steve's are
pretty big to bust but
i like a lot of work i like to roast
people and that's how i've always gotten
along with guy friends and
in high school i had a ton of guy
friends
and we just like roast each other you
know so but sometimes
guys think that's flirting and it's and
i'm not
that's just how sometimes it is
you are my husband sorry guys so the
answer is
women are complicated
i learned that if you were if you notice
if you start noticing this that
if you're in a group setting and
something funny happens the first person
you look at
yeah but also i do that just because
like
if someone has the same sense of humor
as me i feel like i'm like i want you to
know that like we're laughing yeah
because we maybe get it more than
someone else but it's not like
i like them that's true i notice that i
do that like if i like someone and i'm
laughing the first person i look at is
them
unless it's like a group of like really
obvious like look we're all just friends
and it's just like okay we have the same
sentence
in new girl it's who your toes are
pointed at
when you're standing my toes toes are
pointing
what
yeah okay this is getting crazy
remember nikki is sober yeah i'll
remember
keep checking us in with that one this
is true yeah
so it's not to partake this is true um
not so subtle yeah i don't know not so
obvious ways i've
i'm definitely never a flirter i'm the
girl that tells the guy's friend hey i
like your friend
hook it up dude i wouldn't even have the
balls to do that i wouldn't do that
yeah i was so not a girl that went after
a guy that she wanted
oh so not i seem to see if they're
interested first before i put on the big
moves you know
the big mood moves yeah that's true
that's safe
because you don't want to put the big
moves on the the person it's like
rejected
chill like oh where's my guys deserve to
be rejected
well if he sends his friend to ask my
friend if i'm into him then
he doesn't have to deal with the
rejection either yeah that's a [ __ ] way
to move through
life okay all right um
the next question is when you swallow
is because is it because assumptions
yeah
i hate i hate it and when you swallow
it's because you like it or because
you think we like it really i love that
no i don't it gives me a stomachache
every [ __ ] time
every time i've swallowed calm i've had
a stomachache after and i [ __ ] hate
it
so this last and the cumbersome the last
time um
okay i have to tell you guys this is
really [ __ ] like awkward for me
the last time i was with the guy before
quarantine um i was hooking up with this
guy
and i sucked his dick and i was like oh
i don't want to swallow it because my
stomach hurts
but i don't want him to think i'm not
cool so i'm gonna hold it
in my mouth until he passes out because
like usually i'll give him a
solid ass bj who held it it takes like
10 minutes they'll fall asleep and then
i can kind of quietly go
you know i held it in the back of my
mouth but then i [ __ ] like
something like in my nose happened to
where i went you know and then and so
i was forced to swallow it so then i was
like oh [ __ ] so i swallowed it on
accident but a little bit you know when
you drink water and it goes down the
wrong hole yeah so a little bit of the
cup
down the wrong hole and so i was choking
on it and it was just a whole [ __ ]
problem or deal that you had a great
baby in your shoulder
baby just swallowed it even though i
didn't want to or she just got up and
spat it out because i know i don't want
to because it gives me a [ __ ]
stomachache dude
you gotta mask it like after he comes in
your mouth he didn't know that get it
out and just be like oh yeah it's
because my spit is so wet well you gotta
ask
you gotta have the water roll or
something and then you pretend to drink
yes and he's like i'm so thirsty can you
hand me the water but i was trying to be
cool you know like because
immediately like the first time you suck
his dick you want to be like pit yeah
you're disgusting
that's trying to play it cool i
swallowed like the first couple times
yeah you got to solve the first few
times just to like let them know you
don't hate them or are disgusted by it
and then also like i want you to be
pleased right
then you know i don't enjoy swallowing
comments i am the odd man out there no
i love it too no no not that i love it
nah girl we got it gina you love coke i
love
that [ __ ] for breakfast lunch at dinner
it doesn't give you a stomachache
no i feel like that shit's trying to
impregnate me and it's just like yeah
it's just swimming in there i'm insane
so i think it's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah all right why are you the odd man
out i'm the odd man now because
i cannot like my gag reflex i can't even
let it
i can't have him come in my mouth oh
like it always you feel like the shoot
shoot shooting
yeah and then i gag and i'm like i'm
gonna throw up on your dick
like it's hard to sometimes yeah some
guys but um
and he actually was like just go for it
once and i was like no no no no he was
like i want to see you puke
yeah when we first started dating he was
really into like head [ __ ] stuff
because it's weird and
uh i was just like i can't do this i'm
too vanilla for this [ __ ]
i can't and i'll get there one day
probably maybe
i don't know but as of now and i will i
will take the ridicule
and be like so where does he come on
your face or what uh
sometimes or like on my stomach or just
like me jerking you just like finish in
the mouth
yeah just not in the mouth like if i'm
if i'm going down on him then
like i'll end up he'll tell me like oh
i'm gonna come and then i'll start
stroking it and then like that's how
he'll finish but
i just can't have it in my mouth throw
up i get it i get it it's not the
greatest
thing but it's just cleaner and more
environmentally friendly because we
don't have to use napkins to clean it up
you [ __ ] issues well i'm like come
with my [ __ ]
like yeah because you have a husband
yeah
well i mean so do you but we're talking
about blow jobs yeah yeah so what you
just give them [ __ ] and then you put
it in really
because usually the the yeah that's how
it goes
that's why before like when we first
when i first got off of birth control
and then we weren't trying to get
pregnant because i was like trying to
cleanse my body out of the hormones or
whatever that's what would happen like
he was just
not on my stomach i i like um
now that i'm off birth control even when
i was on i don't like it when they come
inside like i think it's hot like don't
get me wrong it's really hot
but man doesn't [ __ ] up my kind of not
worth it yeah yeah
i guess they smell weird the next couple
weeks yeah like my
my my little lady you don't drink enough
water for
your internal vagina to like flush
itself out fast enough so it kind of
like
sits up yeah so for me you gotta do that
you gotta take a bath and kind of flush
it out same i i point it up to the
water faucet hose thing get a bidet that
too that's who
um but yeah like for me like i think
it's so hot when he comes inside me but
at times like it's almost not worth it
because i'll smell weird it feels
super [ __ ] weird too like it's like
this weird viscosity that's like
yeah it's thing it just feels like what
the [ __ ] is that
like when it smells weird i don't want
you to go down on me it's like a big ass
booger
yeah it's like a weird [ __ ]
slime mm-hmm i don't know i like it
all up in there yeah that's hot i like
doing it right before dinner like if
we're going out somewhere
and then like the people don't know that
yeah but it you
kind of smell that come though when it
comes out like i've done that before and
then i go into the restaurant
bathroom to go pee and i'm like oh i
smell the [ __ ] okay
i smell it i hope no one else can and
then you tell yourself like i'm such a
[ __ ]
i love it nikki gets it i love it i'm
just kind of like i hope no one else can
smell this
[ __ ] all over me like if i would ever
call it know that i'm a [ __ ]
super super whatever i forgot
i just gave up on that yeah the [ __ ]
superstar oh yeah
you [ __ ] saw that yeah
if i ever go over to tiff and casey's
house and i smell coconut oil i will
throw up oh
it's all over our bedsheets baby
isaac you'll know now if you smell it
leave oh my god
it came over and the magnum condoms were
on the sideboard like as if it was an ad
i was like um you know you forgot to put
that away right
she's like we didn't forget we want you
to know we were gonna ask
um but yeah like it's just not worth it
for me to come inside now
i like the whole coming to my mouth
thing because one i dig it
spitters aren't quitters or spitters or
quitters and gina's not a quitter
i wouldn't quit if it didn't give me a
stomachache yeah that's very strange i
wonder why that i don't know what it is
tummy ache it takes about 15 minutes and
within about 15 minutes of swallowing
come then my stomach hurts
whatever stomach hurt feeling you feel i
get that
as it's coming in my mind hey just
really what's your what's your blood
type
oh me too you ever read that book eat
right for your blood type
maybe it just doesn't work doesn't work
for our blood type
it works for me just fine ladies and
gentlemen stop ruining our theory
but also usually when i'm sucking dicks
though i've had a lot of tequila or
something so maybe it's just a mixture
oh okay you gotta feel gonna have a full
stomach
i probably i think if i eat a whole meal
eat some bread before you swallow yeah
usually there's not a lot of food going
on before
yeah oh my gosh some biscuits i'll eat a
taco
toast what do you remember that
girlfriend that i told you that's an
escort yeah
she dated this guy for the longest time
and then um
she was like uh you know how i knew he
was the one i was like okay sure
and then she's like dude this [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] freak and i like how a lot of
people are like
gina's obviously talking about herself
she's escorted no gina's not the escort
shut up that would be a lot richer
she was like the the reason i like the
when i realized he was the one was
because we were having sex one day
and then i was just like do you want to
try like just come on a piece of toast
and i can eat it and he was all about it
so we made we got a piece of bread he
came on it and i ate it and that's when
i knew he was the one
and i was just like wow that's i feel
like any guy would have said yes to that
yeah same
i can't imagine a guy saying no to that
yeah would you say no to coming on a
piece of toast yeah bryce if it was like
you eat your own come on a piece of
toast then think about it he was really
into it then yeah right don't do it
every guy would do it if bryce would do
it any guy would do it yeah
he's not the one it's not a weird
question if bryce would do it anyway i
would do it
so that's how she knew and i mean they
didn't last but i was like oh that's
oh i thought he was the one who was the
one it's not that special bryce would do
it either
everybody bryce you're special you're a
special brand i said he's kinky i would
come on a toast for her
she she rarely if i could come on a
piece of toast and feed it to a guy i
would yeah
i mean she's hot so i think a lot of
people would but then like i just never
heard of that before and i was just like
you know what if that
gets rocks off then congratulations
maybe not toast because
toast is kind of bland maybe like a
dried cake yeah
chocolate cinnabon chocolate croissant
something like consistency works better
yeah or maybe some honey yeah maybe
maybe you can mix it in with some honey
or you can just download this extension
called honey and save lots of money on
online shopping
so we all shop online and we've seen
that promo code field taunt us
at checkout because you're always like
damn it i wish i had a code i get so mad
every time i don't have one i try to
search for one at the last second
exactly but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing
of the past because honey is a free
browser extension that finds promo codes
for you and automatically applies them
to your cart
so i mean honestly i have gone through
this so many times because
back in the day i used to try to google
like the store number
or like the store name and then try to
find promo codes and you have to like
check every single code and it takes an
eternity and then you end up finding out
three of them don't work you don't even
get a code because they all have been
used already or whatever it is but honey
automatically searches and filters
through a ton of promo codes that are
available
online so once you are shopping and you
go to the checkout there will be like a
little pop-up
and you could click apply coupons and
then you just wait a few seconds and
honey scans its database for all the
working coupons
for that site and then you can watch the
prices drop and just
get savings so like recently i
um oh we actually saved some money on
amazon when isaac was purchasing his
his um yes thank you like some of his pc
items there were some
codes that really helped and saved us
some money so
honey has found it's over 17 million
members over
two billion dollars in savings if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up
missing out on free money it's literally
free
and installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting
this podcast get honey for free at
joinhoney.com mood that's
com slash m-o-o-d
yeah and if you want something to eat
that's better than toast
um yeah if you don't want to eat come
toast
and you want something healthy and
delicious hello hellofresh
is has got something for you hello fresh
offers so many recipes to choose from
every week
to help you break out of your recipe rut
and offers fresh high quality
ingredients every week for a super
flavorful experience
save time cut out cut out the stressful
meal planning grocery store tip
trips and all that stuff you can make um
any
meal in just about 30 minutes or even 20
minutes with their quick recipe options
they've got a lot of sustainable
ingredients and they're giving back okay
hellofresh donated over 2.5 million
meals to charity in 2019
and this year is stepping up their food
donations amid the coronavirus
crisis um i love hellofresh i love
making it look like the pictures and i'd
love that they can cater to any diet so
i do the vegetarian ones and then steve
will do like the
carnivore omni you can also pick how
many people are in your family too so if
you have
a bigger family or if it's just a single
person you could put a family of four
and just save a whole bunch of meals
oh because meal prep them all hell yeah
so yeah try out america's number one
meal kit go to hellofresh.com
big mood 80 and use code big mood 80 to
get a total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first box additional restrictions apply
please visit hellofresh.com for more
details again go to hellofresh.com
big mood 80 and use code big mood 80 to
get a total of
80 off including free shipping on your
first box additional restriction apply
please visit
hellofresh.com for more details it's so
good you will swallow all of it
moving on jesus christ
so i found a couple questions that i
just thought were so ridiculously funny
we don't have to answer them but it's
so dumb um do you ever put two fingers
in your vagina to push out your poop
when it's a hard one
excuse me dude oh they think it's like
they're tainted like words wait
i'm trying which makes me picture a man
pushing on their team
to get a piece of [ __ ] out because the
the
vaginal and the butt share a wall
so if you just go in there and you just
push it out a little bit just guide it a
little bit doesn't work
i've never i've never
i don't think there's just like [ __ ]
like lined up across your vagina i think
like your vagina goes this way and then
like your anus
yeah like look up goes like this
the trick that i learned was if you have
one that's just not coming out
like it's just just really shocked on my
stomach when i was younger i'm like yeah
right you rock back and forth back and
forth yeah that's how you get the [ __ ]
out yeah
yeah we got some [ __ ] tips for you
never thought that was gonna happen here
all the guys that were like jerking into
this whole episode are like
oh yeah you ever got a piece of [ __ ] in
there just rock that you know
you wiggle it out
gina thank you so much for the tip about
holding your fart and thank you
thank you you are welcome citizens
yeah if you have to park yeah dude if i
if i have too far i just squat and i'm
like okay this should work
or i don't do anything i just wait for
it why are you guys trying to force them
because they get stuck
i i don't really fart but like the few
times i've had
that gas bubble i had to put a pillow
there
or do child's pose or do some sort of
maneuvering i don't do any of those
yeah also if you're having a hard time
pooping blow your nose while you're
on the boat really yeah it forces your
butt's like yeah you can also do
anything
you can just bear down no like if you if
you're like feeling like it's there but
it's not coming out
just blow your nose you're just bearing
down on your abdominal wall or that yeah
i don't know how to do that just
normally so just blow your nose or just
cough
but then if you ever go to my bathroom
and i hear you coughing i know exactly
what you're doing
yeah anyone coughing is doing that
anymore oh yeah every like coronavirus
is
why they're just all just trying to
stupid-ass [ __ ]
question i love these questions keep
going
there's another one that says
if i blow in one boob does the other get
bigger what the
[ __ ] are these guys ten they sound like
child
yeah i had to write these down because
they were hilarious they were obviously
joking
yeah okay i mean obviously it does
um this one says does every girl have a
gangbang
factory fantasy sorry i can't read my
drunken handwriting fantasy well it's a
yes
for me yeah yes for me yes for me it's a
no for me
really but that scares me too many but
how about
but for us that said yes would you want
that in real life though because
i don't think i would want it in real
life it's just the fantasy of
being completely dominated yeah yeah i
don't i don't even have a fantasy
there are some there are some exceptions
there there would be very strict
if i could pick each guy like say it was
tom hardy and shia labeouf and like
maybe a guy i know in real life that i
have a super hardcore crush on like if
the three of them wanted to come at me i
would take those three dicks
i would figure out a way to take those
three dicks but if it's just
three guys like that aren't special i
don't know
yeah true circumstantial circumstantial
if i'm like really into it i mean
i don't know i just i i don't know if it
will ever actually happen yeah
but i'm not going to say that i would
stop it if it
yeah but it's hard to find three guys
that would [ __ ] you
i say yes i say yes like i would
probably be down for it but like i said
it'll be hard to find the three guys it
would not be hard ladies
guys guys don't want to be in the same
room as another guy
yeah that's the hard part so you have to
find someone that you're attracted to
and they're willing to be in a room with
three other guys where their balls are
stopping against each other maybe
so seeing another dick in the same room
as them a lot of guys will get soft
they're not down
yeah so it's and then also it's like it
would be very strict like here's an nda
give me your cell phones no cell phones
this is not my real name oh [ __ ] i
didn't even think about that
i don't have much of a career anyway
so yeah that's the other thing too and
my fantasy is like
um they're all like you know taking
pictures
yeah wow i am so
[ __ ] vanilla man like maybe we're
just like we just like
really like like really vanilla i think
it's just the dominance thing right
so it's like it's not it's like i
wouldn't want any of that to happen
but i think about it like in a it's like
a
complete i think i need to just have a
little bit more of an open mind because
before i was really like
uh or i guess i wasn't against being
dominated but like
i don't know like don't you watch
lesbian porn like that was the what you
were interested to swing the other way a
little bit in your fantasies well
because like i tried thinking i'm like
um i i don't know man like my fantasies
are [ __ ] boring like they're not
anything special there's nothing wrong
with that though yeah there's nothing
wrong with that there's nothing that's
like exciting about it
and like the lesbian thing like the only
reason why i like watching
women is because it's just so like
women's bodies are just way
nicer to look at like i wouldn't want to
just like stare like get off at a dick
for for me like i don't i don't find
like penis genitals like attractive to
what about like just the male body like
okay
i recently had this conversation with
casey and what we were saying
was like so for me if i see like i could
get turned on by like a really hot guy
but in
even by looking at him i'm not even
looking at the dick like the dick is
like
like uh like um what's the word it's
just [ __ ] garbage that you're not
looking at
yeah it's just like like yeah pretty
much i'm just like i'm not looking like
i'm trying to blur that part
it is it's like blurry it's like a it's
like a blemish on the whole
thing so i'm sorry your dicks are
blemishes
i like your dicks your dicks are
beautiful that you're beautiful
honestly no no obviously i enjoy like i
[ __ ]
love casey's dick but i wouldn't like it
just visually
it's not something that i'm trying to
look at yeah maybe you just have like a
thing that you're not
fully aware of yeah so that's why like i
would rather if i do watch porn
like i tried watching like just regular
porn and like the dick is in the way
i'm just like i don't know if there's
probably a lot of girls like you
i think there's a lot of girls that are
yeah for me and when i'm watching porn
i it can't be in a different language
because and it's about like how they're
talking to her too
oh like really yeah like she can't be
liking it
and then also can't be liking it
excuse me what like not that like
she can't be like controlling them where
she's like oh yeah give me your d
she can't be the same like she has two
it's too much acting yeah she needs to
be more like completely submissive
and then um the guys need to be like
super condescending
you know usually i am more dominant in
bed but then like this last time where i
was like oh let's try
you being more dominant because i like i
just i want to see what that's like
and then i prefer that a lot more don't
worry being dominant yes
girl it took me a long time to realize
that but i agree
yeah yeah yeah that leads us into our
next question
uh what kind or what part of porn do you
like
there we go there you go i just told you
i don't like looking in full nelson
position what's full what else i got i
can't explain it to you but
i am really big on close-ups of the
penis going in the vagina
yeah that shit's hot that's pretty great
penetration
hot yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about your
face i like it when they're actually
like a couple because like i've seen a
i've seen a few where i'm like oh
they're like boyfriend girls yeah they
were actually a couple hotel
because like he'll kind of do some like
sweet things to her and then he'll
[ __ ] pound her and i'm like
he loves her and he's [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of her and i respect that
i really like that it's cute yeah i
can't do it because i like like high
i like hd 4k there's like craft surfaces
in the back
you know like there's a makeup table
yeah i don't like when it's too actory
or where they focus on the storyline too
oh i don't care
no i skipped that storyline is totally
useless dude i [ __ ] mute it so i'm
like i don't even know what's happening
like like audio-wise but the weird one
that i
i looked at myself and i'm like this is
so on vanilla of you
well i don't know you guys can growth
let's hear it um no
so the animation ones oh my god are you
into hentai
so it wasn't
it wasn't hentai it was like a different
it wasn't like japanese
yeah yeah like cartoon and then there
were these shots
this one video oh i feel so awkward
so there was this one it was like a
pokemon one
which i didn't mean to like make it
japanese yeah but
but they like the the actual like the
animation of it look more cartoony
anyway the point is that they had shots
of like internally oh yes and i was like
this is
hot that's a big thing yeah and what do
you mean internally
like you could like it's like a imagine
you're a tiny little person inside the
vagina and you see the dick coming in
and that really turned me on and i was
like this is so on vanilla
they have porn is that is it i don't
know they have poorly put the camera
inside the vagina
what yeah like real life scared of it
getting stuck in there
yeah real life oh [ __ ] oh i don't know
about if i want to see them look up for
that by another
it's so dark in there is it like i think
they light up they have a little dp that
goes in there
you know what like right now i just had
like a like a like a memory
i think i know why that turned me on so
when i was younger there was this movie
that i watched i don't even know what
movie this was
but it it was like a it showed like a
real life
kind of footage of like the sperm going
towards an egg
and it was like about making a baby i
think it was like um look who's talking
i don't know oh yeah
was it that one yeah yeah so then like i
just
knowing that it was like inside i think
like when i was a little kid like that
i remember the same thoughts yeah like
whoa
so maybe that's where it came from yeah
i go through like phases like i was in
i was like really into the dp phase at
one point
yeah me too penetration
at the same time i don't want it in my
butthole but i like watching that
it's only two it's only because the
dicks are touching
through the walls that's why i like it
it has nothing to do with like the girl
getting
doubly penetrated it's like oh my god
two guys dicks are touching to me
it's like when they're kind of gay and i
kind of like
to me it's that's when that's happening
and there's one in her mouth it's like
all of her holes are completely diffused
yeah
i just imagine her being like oh my gosh
yeah basically yeah
i mean like i'm into like when he pulls
the wiener out and he spreads her [ __ ]
with his hands a little bit it's like
that's [ __ ] dope
i don't like that because that [ __ ]
hurts when they do that that's not hard
that hard you're [ __ ] oh my god i
don't want anything to happen to me
like pull it apart too much and i know
how that feels so i'm like ow stop
stop ripping my [ __ ] sometimes i
don't even need to watch the porn i just
like the titles turn me on
like like come urinal wow
what does that mean i'm like
okay fourth of july park glory hole
dude i can't i can't read the titles
because they're always interested it's
too much yeah and it's like
that it's so hard i have to hurry up
past the title
what categories are you looking at you
gotta look at no like on the homepage or
whatever it pops up yeah i go
i go to the categories which category do
you click bang bang
or cream pie oh i don't do that one i
always go to hot guys [ __ ]
oh i like to look at a ripped man
recently i started looking at the old
guys ones oh no
old guy one i was just curious mickey
lima i was curious
like the guilt the grandpa yeah oh man
i i am disgusted i'm a big fan of see my
favorite is like
full nelson compilations but what the
[ __ ] is that described with full nelson
can i just show you guys a picture
yeah close up oh it's right
it was a close-up it's it's this one
that's the position
so i guess what we need to if you don't
know what full nelson is it's a girl
facing the camera her ass is facing the
camera and her legs are
all the way up behind her ears and then
the dick is coming see all of it
yeah it's like missionary almost almost
i think reverse cowgirl almost
i just don't like what the vagina looks
like it looks too true it looks like the
anatomy books in health class and i'm
like i don't
yeah i don't same way i don't want to
look at a vagina yeah
i'd rather see it i like the vagina so
like if it's like that
i don't know if it's like that i could
see it but i don't want to see the
girl's face
i just want to see it i hate the girl's
face
yeah i don't like her face or vagina i'd
rather see a bunch of dudes
takes me out of it exactly i like seeing
the vagina and then i look up
compilations because then it's almost
like watching 20 videos in one and i'd
have to keep on clicking
i think because i've never seen my own
vagina that way so it's not part of
myself my sex experience
like seeing a vagina takes me out my own
vagina
yeah if i would like if i would have
like a preference like when i go on a
porn site and i look at categories for
me it's
dildo writing oh like okay
interesting so there's no dick at all no
dick you just kind of yeah
you just don't like dicks i just don't
like looking at it yeah
i don't know well that works there's a
ton there's a ton of people like that
but then if you ask me if i would ever
be down to like have a sexual experience
with a girl i don't think
i can actually bring myself to do that
like still too weird because i don't
either i have only ever like kissed a
girl and that
like really like so grossed me out yeah
it was too
soft too feminine like too much where i
was just like
i can't do this same yeah like i've had
a threesome with another girl but now i
just realized like
i'm really straight yeah i'm i'm really
straight there's like no
i'm unnecessarily straight
like offensively straight well that's
called homophobia
oh no no no i like the guy so i like the
gay guy
ah true okay that makes sense um yeah
like i i
i appreciate them and they're beautiful
like holy [ __ ] i want her to ruin my
life but like not in a you know like i'm
not in a sexual
yeah um last question is um
how do you how do you masturbate with
long nails
yeah it's the palm of it's like the like
the meaty part of your finger
part but the problem with me though is i
like to masturbate while he's hitting it
missionary style
but remember back then when i used to
have really long nails that actually
gets in the way
it's done rubbing and i'll actually stab
him oh yeah
dude recently recently i was ovulating
so that's like when you're the horniest
right and i don't i just got a wave of
like
horniness dude i don't know who this
last one okay ovulation
okay it's crazy but i was so i was
wearing jeans
and i just like barely touched the seam
of my jeans against it and i had a
full-on orgasm oh
wait can i add the next question to that
then yeah so you guys get randomly horny
like we do
yes yep yes out of the blue extremely
but for me it's never a constant thing
like throughout my
i used to think i just had really low
libido but then every time that
like for me i think my libido comes from
how well
the relationship is going and so like
recently we've been doing really really
really good and so
now i just have like a really high
libido yeah that helps yep yeah
but i'm single and i just get horny as
[ __ ] but i'll be horny for like three
days straight and i'll masturbate like
72 times
it just doesn't go away yeah yeah that's
true it's such a it's it's like
it's such a [ __ ] you from nature because
you get the most horny when you're on
your period
oh man not me really oh ovulation yeah
yeah put a dick in there and put it in a
baby in there
yeah i don't want the baby though when
i'm on my period it's like i need the
baby
if i get pregnant i'll give you the baby
thank you sometimes though like during
my period i'd be like whoa
yeah but i'm like wait right now it's
not baby making time as for like a long
nails thing if i have long nails i never
put it inside me
no no no no even videos like like i said
i like watching like girl stuff
but if they have long nails it hurts me
they'll they'll put it inside i've seen
a girl put two fingers inside with nails
and i'm like [ __ ] aren't you
aren't you i forgot some guys like maybe
not don't even know that
like the main way that girls masturbate
is that the clitoris
not like my fingering i usually do both
but
yeah but the thing what what gets you to
orgasm the most
clitoral yeah but the inside it makes it
faster
so like if it's dual it's faster yeah
same but i don't go like
all the way in dildo and then i focus on
the [ __ ] and yeah that's it
that works or like a if you put one hand
on your
on your butt a little bit yeah that
helps yeah yeah
you like smack it and then you like
squeeze it out smack it
i learned the pressure yeah i learned
that if you press on your
uh what's the space like your gooch
throw some really have a good
yeah if you push on that real hard when
you're coming i think for both men and
women it makes you comfortable i think
it's just the butthole yeah
so just go closer to the bottom yeah
it's better yeah there's no like
you might accidentally get lost in there
yeah you all
you you did the butt plug thing exactly
that's what i'm saying yeah it's like
good
i don't know it doesn't have to really
it doesn't really affect my orgasm i
don't feel like it
yeah all right we gotta wrap it up like
a condom now
wrap it up kids i know you guys don't
want this one to end because man there
was a lot of this
relationship it was we can do another
yeah another version pulling
questions from reddit yeah yeah you guys
can ask
hundreds of questions guys probably want
to know they're too free to ask yeah
guys if you are listening and you an
anonymous
anonymously want to ask questions you
can submit it to our
big mood uh dms on i on youtube
instagram on ig
i might judge you from your photos
because i'm the one going through the
questions but i won't tell anyone
thanks for watching guys make sure you
guys subscribe and like give us a good
rating on
itunes because it really helps us out a
lot and if you guys have any questions
that you're afraid to ask
put it in the comments send it to our dm
and um just
if you wanted those dm's if you want
maybe if you want to make one of what we
talked about today do it i might block
you but whatever
you have don't yuck our yums this is a
safe space
by the way p.s yeah all right we'll see
you guys next week bye we love you